i
ah
[Música]
'ecuador despenalizó el aborto por
duración la corte constitucional
resolverá demanda de
inconstitucionalidad del año 2020 por
organizaciones feministas y de derechos
humanos en contra el artículo 149 y 150
del código orgánico integral penal que
permitía el aborto sólo en caso de
peligro para la madre o por violación a
una mujer que sufriera de discapacidad
mental o magistrados declara
inconstitucional la frase mujer que
padezca de una discapacidad mental con
este fallo no se podrá criminalizar a
una mujer por aborto en caso de incesto
estupro inseminación no consentida o
malformación del feto el fallo de la
corte encarga la defensoría del pueblo a
que presente un proyecto ante la
asamblea nacional para que el país
andino regule cómo se aplicará la
interrupción del embarazo en los
servicios públicos y privados una
decisión rechazada por la conferencia
episcopal y por parte del presidente
electo entrante guillermo lasso pero que
aseguró respetar a la decisión de la
corte
[Música]
en república dominicana la cámara de
diputados aprobó en primera lectura el
aborto en una única causal cuando
peligra la vida de la persona embarazada
muchos ven en este paso un avance ya que
república dominicana es de los pocos
países del mundo en que el aborto está
totalmente prohibido la discusión se da
en medio de la creación de un nuevo
código penal todavía hay que esperar la
votación de los diputados en segunda
lectura después pasar al senado y
finalmente al ejecutivo la mayoría de
diputados votó en contra de otras dos
causales excepcionales la violación o
incesto y la inviabilidad del feto desde
marzo se llevan a cabo manifestaciones a
favor y en contra del aborto grupos de
feministas que reclaman se incluyen las
tres causales mantienen un campamento
desde el 11 de marzo frente al ejecutivo
y anunciaron una marcha para el 23 de
mayo el presidente luís abinader ha
dicho que sometería la decisión a un
referéndum mientras que la onu instó al
país a despenalizar el aborto en sus
tres causales
[Música]
recientemente un grupo de mujeres se
concentró para honrar y conmemorar los
11 años de la muerte de manuel a una
salvadoreña condenada en 2008 a 30 años
de prisión por el delito de homicidio
agravado tras sufrir complicaciones
obstétricas y ser acusada de provocarse
un aborto dos años después en 2010
falleció de cáncer linfático esposada a
la cama de un hospital en el salvador el
aborto está prohibido en todas sus
formas y se castiga con prisión es así
que año con año decenas de mujeres que
sufren pérdidas o complicaciones durante
su embarazo son enviadas a la cárcel por
el delito de aborto y en muchos casos
son condenadas por homicidio agravado el
caso de manuela es el primero de este
tipo en ser revisado por la corte
interamericana de derechos humanos en
este se denuncia al estado por
violaciones a sus derechos y los de su
familia de acuerdo con organizaciones
feministas un fallo favorable además de
ser histórico podría evitar que otras
mujeres pasen por la misma situación en
un país con una de las leyes santiago
son más estrictas del mundo
[Música]